thanks Elena I think I'm no exception in
changing the title to fit nicely into
the workshop but also I am very grateful
to the organizers for having me here and
for giving me the opportunity to give
this very short talk so without further
ado I don't have a lot of time but I
would just want to give a flavour of the
latest things that I've been working on
together with a couple of quarters that
are hiding somewhere
I cannot spot some but they are here and
so traditionally could you know could be
could be scripted systems like McAleese
and similar make use of error correcting
codes as we've seen in the description
of Tanya earlier and of the hardness of
the coding random in our code it so it's
important that we somehow link to the
happiness of cinder decoding problem
which is based on random code that we
want our codes to be indistinguishable
from random which is why we study the
code equivalence problem in a sense what
is the balance problem well in the
simplest formulation equivalent codes
traditionally in coding theory are
records that are possible to map via
permutation so if you can map code Wars
to the other code rules via permutation
and then this notion can be extended if
you if you use linear isometries in the
following way so instead of just
permuting we permute and we had a
scaling factor here so you can imagine
that it's a similar concept just a bit
more generic yes so here we could we
talked about linear code equivalence and
we said the codes are linearly
equivalent we can formulate all this
using generator matrices like normal for
the code so we say that two codes are
permutation or equivalent if there are
matrices SMT such that G prime is equal
to SGP which is kind of like the
standard case and the linear equivalent
case corresponds to using a matrix Q
which is a monomial matrix yes you can
imaginary you take a matrix which is a
diagonal times a permutation for example
and then this leads to the following
formulation of the problem which is a
respectable permutation or linear code
equivalents problem so given two code C
and C Prime essentially determine
whether the two codes are premutation or
equivalent or
quickly okay so at a glance what what is
the story with the cocoon is probably
being studied for a very long time and
there is a proof by Patrick and rot that
shows that this program is not very
likely to be np-complete unless
collapsable you know my hierarchy but at
the same time they also mentioned that
the problem is not too easy right and as
a matter of fact there are some existing
algorithms that efficiently attack the
problem in certain particular cases but
under everything the complexity still
somewhat exponential and it's easy to
find some instances there are
intractable so you can quickly come up
with instances that are hard to solve
and of course there is a difference here
we mentioned between the parameters as
they are chosen usually for code base
cryptography in terms of being able to
decode versus using codes that don't
need to do that actually and this is
exactly the point so could we actually
use code equivalence alone to do stuff
and I will not divulge here too much
about the construction of the schemes
because it's supposed to be a
cryptanalysis talk but indeed the
situation kind of recalls that of
discrete logarithms except that the
action or linear geometry is not
commutative so in a sense we're kind of
a little more akin to the situation of
Sajha needs to so to speak but for
example we can do we can we can adapt
some existing construction to be based
on code equivalence and the selling
point is that of course we have a big
computational advantage because the
arithmetic is is obvious linear algebra
essentially so we have zero knowledge
protocol which we can obtain and sort of
a standard way and then we can conquer
we can transform this into a signal a
proper signature scheme use in future
mail with very very good performance it
may be also possible to do other stuff
like for example a signature a proper
signature scheme without fishimene
following the el-gamal framework and
this would lead to even more efficient
instantiation and maybe you know what we
would like to do really is to come up
with
of the Fierman again so this was already
something very creative in the case of a
sahaja nice and in our case it would be
more heated but we are certainly working
on it so what about cryptanalysis then
well one first thing to keep in mind is
that Leon in 1982 introduced this method
to find out amorphous group of a code
and it's very likely that this can be
adapted to sort potential permutation
equivalent if we focus on a subset of a
certain fixed weight of code words and I
will just studied the action of the
permutation on this subset and indeed if
we set this weight to say for example
just a little bit more than the GV bound
find a sweet spot which is you know big
enough but not too big then then we can
then we can recover that and the
bottleneck of the algorithm is that we
have to enumerate all the code words of
that weight at least this is how we at
initial assessment and I see the ant one
is shaking his head so we may have some
development but okay if we do that then
obviously the complexity is rather big
and this means that is really only
efficient for codes of small dimension
or a small finite seeds and again it's
possible that there is a more clever way
to do this right and in fact there is
already a more clever way to do this
which is the super splitting algorithm
which was introduced in 2000 by family
and this is in fact a dedicated
algorithm for the permutation
equivalence case and here this uses the
concept of signature function which is
in a sense a characteristic of the code
something that makes the code
recognizable in the sense that I can map
the code and a certain position to the
permitted version and I can you know say
that the signature is fully discriminant
if this is true so whenever I change
positions I never get collision and so
of course if I am able to find the fully
discriminant signature then I can
efficiently distinguish the code
so what's what's the difficult part here
is that finding a full discriminant
signature is not abuse and they think
the Sun they proposed is to do is to
build the hull of the code which is the
code intersected with its dual and then
you can do some fancy stuff you can
puncture and compute the weight
enumerator and essentially you're able
to compute such a discrete you can find
such a fully discriminant signature
there and the complexity scales
accordingly and you see that the
dominant term here is this not a linear
algebra right but is the q2 the
dimension of the hull and interestingly
so this hull and I think that Tania said
a couple of things about this it's you
know for typical cryptographic
parameters it's is rather small right so
this is efficient when the hull is small
except for the case where the hell is
actually empty this case was that was
studied recently by birthday out money
inside but if the heart grows really big
then this algorithm is obviously
exponential in that right so mmm the
worst case in this scenario is weakly
serve dual codes which the dimension of
the hull is maximum yeah so so it's
actually the algorithm makes make makes
the case intractable if we use with
waitress at work with software code and
now we're talking about permutation
equivalent but in fact the case of
linear clearance can also be solved if
we start working on the closures of the
code which is this following notion so
the culture of a code is essentially the
code seed which we have exploded right
using our alphabets we get another
linear code which is longer than n times
Q minus 1 and then the fundamental point
is that if the two codes are linear
equivalent then their closure our
permutation or equivalent and vice versa
and so in fact
solving linear equivalents correspond to
solving permutation equivalents on the
closures which means we can do the
previous things that we were doing on
the closures right so for Leon we will
enumerate the words of the closure and
for SSA we can actually run this on the
closures because this solves permutation
equivalence but Sunday showed that when
Q is greater or equal than 5 then the
closure of a code is always weakly
softwa and this is exactly the case were
interested in
because then we can take codes which
make SSA and not what about the quantum
because this is after all a quantum
plate analysis workshop so first of all
that is Grover right and we can imagine
to apply Grover to Leon's arburian which
is a search algorithm the mentholated
score and we can at least imagine the
usual speed up right in the in the
search part at least for us to say well
if we try to do a naive global search
over all the possible secrets then this
would not output from the classical
world just because of the size of the
things we're searching but we could also
think of using Google within SSA and so
this would roughly correspond to trying
to find this function here which is
defined as C with the signature function
and try to see when this function is 1
and well in this case the search space
is quite short actually because you are
just looking for the index between 1 and
n right but the Oracle is expensive and
so again the complexity becomes pretty
big and this again does not output from
the classical SSA so for SSA actually
growver does not bring any benefits and
what else can we try to do apart from
Gruber I mean grow various kind of like
the standard go-to thing but another
thing that we can do in this popular is
quantum Fourier sampling I guess right
so in in our case we could search for
this secret subgroup H and G is given by
this where we take invertible matrix
here and permutation right so the usual
situation this was an article by the
Mora Russell in 2011 and well the
article is actually making some
advertisement but you know all we can
say release that in some cases we can
derive an upper bound on the sampling
probability to find this but this is not
really a criterion yeah it's it's not
really guaranteeing any form of art nice
first of all well we could have some
codes that are C possible to attack by
classical means even if they satisfy
this describe in Iran yes and so
is no guarantee of weakness or hardness
in either way so this is as much as has
been done in terms of applying
techniques of continually sampling in so
essentially it's just showing that
Shor's algorithm is not gonna help us in
this case yes it's not it's not exactly
a very useful result but this is what we
have so anything more them can have on
the quantum side of attacking could the
chorus problem would clearly be a
benefit for for us this is all I have
because I think we're also already a
little bit late so thank you for your
time
[Applause]
please it seems like the definition you
yes is for any metal typically I mean
yes so I mean if we're just talking
really about the yeah I mean I don't
think it makes any difference right it
is the same I mean I'm German just
talking here about the code as a break
object and mapping to another code we're
not actually measuring weight of the
code words or
[Applause]